all the parabolic mirror examples we've
been doing so far have been concave and
that just means and you might know
already that what concave means but just
to make it clear they were we were kind
of they were opening out towards the
objects and in most of the cases out
towards the out towards the where the
images were formed so what we cared
about the inside we cared about the
inside surface of the mirror right here
now the way I always remember concave is
it kind of forms a cave you could view
this part right here is the inside of
the cave and we had a bunch of examples
where we had focal points and then this
would here was our principal axis and we
had objects and I showed you how the
light would reflect off of the mirror
and go through the focal points so
that's we did a bunch of examples like
that in the last couple of videos what I
want to do in this video is a quick
example of using a convex parabolic
mirror so let's do a convex convex
parabolic mirror and here we care about
the other side of the mirror we care
about we care about the side that's kind
of not the kind of the outside of the
bowl if you want to view this as the
parabolic Mueller mirror is a bowl so
let's think about that as a little bit
so let's imagine that once again you
have something that's the shape of a
parabola
it has this let me draw a better version
of it so it has the shape of a parabola
this is the principal axis right over
here that is you can almost you that is
the line of symmetry this is still the
focal point that right there is still
the focus but now we're going to assume
that the reflective surface is on the
outside it's on the outside so the
reflective surface is kind of jutting
out towards us as opposed to caving in
that's another way to remember concave
looks like it's caved in here it's
jetting out towards us and let's think
about what would happen if I put an
object if I put an object over here on
the outside assuming that this is a
reflective surface so if I put an object
over here what is going to happen so
let's just do the same exercise but what
we're going to do is we're going to have
one parallel ray
you can just for once again from we can
do raise to go to any direction from any
of these points because there being
there's some light source over here they
never draw the light source but it
reflects diffusely off of this object so
this object is emitting light rays in
every direction but the useful ones the
useful diffuse light rays being emitted
by this object are the ones that are
parallel to the principal axis and the
ones that would go through the focus so
let's do one that's parallel so if
something is parallel to the principal
axis and I'm not doing the math over
here but if it reflects on the outside
of this parabolic mirror it will reflect
in a way that it's light so it looks
like it's coming from the focus so
obviously the focus is on the other side
of this mirror but it would reflect in a
way that it looks like it'll cut it's
coming from the focus so that ray will
reflect like that and then if we have
another ray from the head of this object
from the tip of that arrow and that ray
is going in the direction of the focus
so the focus is there so let me draw the
direction so let's say I have an
incident ray going in the direction of
the focus when that gets reflected it
will reflect parallel to the principal
axis so it will reflect parallel to the
principal axis and so what type of image
is going to be formed here clearly these
two rays will never converge so we can't
form a real image we cannot project it
project that image onto print onto a
screen or cloth and then see it these
two rays are converging but if one were
to observe the Rays they look like
they're there they're diverging from a
single point they look this ray looks
like let me make it clear this one that
just got reflected out parallel it looks
like it's coming from from if you go
straight back behind the mirror and then
this one that's coming out looks like
it's coming out of this point there so
it looks like they're diverging from
this point on the other side of the
mirror and not only does it look like
they're coming from there but the actual
image will look like that we can do it
with other points on this arrow if we
want if you take the bottom of the arrow
that's maybe the easiest light that goes
straight that goes straight to that goes
straight to the actual mirror
we'll then go flecked it straight back
so it would look like it would look like
it's coming from appointed the mirror
back over here now we could do other
things we could we could we could draw
stuff so that you can see what the whole
image we could take points over here and
you would say that that would correspond
to a point over there but the thing that
or I guess the thing that hopefully you
realize from this video is when you're
dealing with the convex parabolic Miller
on the outside the outside is a
reflective surface you're not going to
form a real image you're going to form a
virtual image this is a virtual image
just like you would see in your bathroom
mirror although that's probably not
parabolic I'm guessing and it's also
going to be a smaller image and it's
also going to be a smaller it's also
going to be a smaller image and you see
these types of mirrors all the time
especially around corners you know if
you see a corner let's let me draw a
hallway with corners you'll sometimes
see you'll sometimes see mirrors let me
do it the other way
well you'll sometimes see mirrors so
that people well the mirror might be out
here so that you can see people as
they're coming around the corner and the
reason why these mirrors are useful is
that they reflect light from a lot of
directions and so you can kind of see
around corners and this is not the best
of drawing but I think you've seen these
convex mirrors mirrors that look like
mirrors that look something like this
sometimes you'll also see them at the
aisles of stores at the head of aisles
of stores in this way the store owners
have a good field of view and they can
see if anyone is anyone is a shoplifting
anyway hopefully you found that
interesting